[Musique]
avec nous ce soir au panel José Legault
Sébastien Bovet et pour une première
fois à Spaniel Valérie Gaudreault
rédactrice en chef au journal Le Soleil
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir et
bienvenue Valérie on va commencer par un
dossier qui a continué de faire jaser
beaucoup aujourd'hui on parlait hier de
ces nouvelles cibles d'immigrations qui
ont été annoncées par Ottawa environ 500
000 immigrants par année pour les trois
prochaines années et il y a vraiment
beaucoup de tensions entre Québec et
Ottawa à ce sujet-là on va écouter
d'ailleurs les réactions de Justin
Trudeau et de François Legault
le Québec depuis longtemps la capacité
d'augmenter ces seuils d'immigration je
sais que chaque fois que je parle des
des propriétaires d'entreprise à
Montréal ou en région il soulignent à
quel point c'est important de contrer la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre on sait que
l'immigration en fait la bonne façon est
une réponse à ça alors on sera toujours
là pour aider à monsieur Legault s'il
veut créer plus de croissance économique
au Québec
le parti qui avait
l'objectif le seuil le plus élevé c'est
à 80000 là si vous faites un petit
calcul
23% de 500 000 on serait presque au
double de ce que le participe en propose
le plus
que ça représente donc vraiment là
va falloir que Monsieur Trudeau monsieur
Rodriguez et puis les gens tawa
comprennent qu'on a un défi ici puis
qu'on veut garder le français à long
terme
alors vraiment deux visions qui
continuent de s'affronter il reste
vraiment camper sur leur position celle
de Québec qui veut protéger le français
celle de taïwa qui veut pallier la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui a raison
qui attend faire un premier tour de
table là-dessus j'osais qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
mais ce qu'on voit sur tout ce profilé
derrière ça c'est une réalité qui va
être de plus en plus difficile pour le
Québec à l'intérieur du Canada
le choix d'augmenter aussi
considérablement les seuils des
migrations pour le Canada c'est quand
même un million et demi de personnes en
trois ans c'est un choix qui peut se
justifier d'un point de vue du point de
vue fédéral mais pour le Québec ça ne va
qu'accentuer
la perte de son poids démographique à
l'intérieur du Canada et donc par
conséquent la perte de son poids
politique la perte de son poids
linguistique aussi bien entendu
mais tel est la réalité et cette réalité
là le gouvernement du Québec ne peut pas
y faire grand chose Sébastien
le Québec est dans une position où il a
besoin de main d'oeuvre mais en même
temps il veut préserver le français donc
protéger le français et François Legault
voit pas nécessairement dans
l'immigration même s'il des déclarations
un peu
hasardeuse pendant la campagne
électorale ce qu'il veut c'est de dire
que il faut avoir une capacité
d'intégration pour intégrer ces
immigrants et faire en sorte qu'il
s'intègre avec le français donc je te
défie additionnel mais le Canada aussi
c'est des filles c'est à dire que il y a
une crise du logement les services de
garde des bords dans les écoles on
manque d'enseignant c'est pas seulement
un problème au Canada donc si on amène
plus de nouveaux arrivants ça met une
pression sur les services sociaux
appelons comme ça Canadiens aussi et
donc monsieur Trudeau prend le pari fait
le pari ou prend le parti plutôt de la
lutte à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais
il y a des effets collatéraux à
accueillir autant de monde au Canada et
pas seulement pour la protection du
français au pays mais aussi pour les
structures sociales du pays oui ça se
fait pas en claquant les doigts il faut
bien les accueillir aussi ces gens qui
arrivent dans un tout nouveau pays
Valérie vous voyez ça comment
effectivement c'est beaucoup on a vu les
ces derniers jours on parle d'une
capacité de logement il y a la
main-d'oeuvre pas seulement oui on veut
accueillir pour la main d'oeuvre mais la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre crée aussi par
exemple par rapport au nombre de
logements à la capacité d'accueil à bien
intégrer parce que monsieur Legault et
on le sait a fait bien fait les frais
pendant la campagne de ses propos par
rapport à cette intégration mais les
réels aussi on veut bien que les choses
se fassent bien ce que je retiens aussi
bah c'est effectivement cette dualité
entre besoin d'immigration pour
l'économie monsieur Trudeau je pense que
toujours il y avait peut-être un malin
plaisir peut-être aujourd'hui aller sur
le terrain très économique de monsieur
Legault en disant c'est comme s'il
disait bah si le Québec je vais en
accueillir moins c'est que ça veut pas
participer à sa croissance économique
alors qu'on sait que c'est cheval de
bataille de monsieur Legault alors voilà
donc bien accueillir
réel réel affrontement aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression qu'on a pas terminé et je
pense à notre toute nouvelle ministre
Christine Frechette qui est probablement
une des premières ministres du nouveau
gouvernement à arriver vraiment
de l'action comme ça avec un dossier
aussi chaud ouais et juste un Trudeau
elle dit aussi aujourd'hui on va
travailler avec le Québec pour qui est
le plus d'immigration francophone ça
fait plusieurs fois que le fédéral dit
ça José que le Québec ne prend pas tous
les moyens pour sélectionner des
immigrants dans la francophonie que ça
peut être fait
oui ben il y a plusieurs problèmes là
bon évidemment monsieur Trudeau a promis
aussi plus d'immigration francophone
hors Québec et ça ne s'est pas
matérialiser évidemment
l'immigration sur laquelle le
gouvernement Québec contrôle le pouvoir
de sélection bon c'est quand même
important mais il n'en reste pas moins
que à 50000 par année ça semble énorme
mais ça ne vaut rien faire pour freiner
le déclin la démographie du Québec à
l'intérieur du Canada ça c'est très
clair et même son propre déclin
démographique point parce qu'il faut
rappeler que le Québec est quand même la
société la plus vieillissante en
Amérique du Nord ce n'est quand même pas
rien ce n'est pas un détail et là on
apprend évidemment que le gouvernement
le goût ne réutilisé en tout cas selon
la presse que qu'une fraction peut pas
mettre 5 % des sommes quand même
importantes que le gouvernement fédéral
transféré au Québec l'an dernier pour la
cotisations et l'intégration donc il y a
plein de morceaux à ce poste là qui nous
manque encore pour comprendre vraiment
ce qui se passe mais pour moi le la
question fondamentale demeure celle du
décret démographique du Québec seul ou à
l'intérieur du Canada là où il va avoir
l'air encore plus accentuée bien entendu
parce que les populations vont continuer
de monter de manière importante au
Québec puis là dessus la réaction
François Legault a été un peu molle
j'avais l'impression aujourd'hui c'est à
dire de dire nous avons des gardes de
fous pour préserver l'influence du
Québec canadien du Canada
l'exemple qu'il a donné c'est le nombre
de députés à la Chambre des communes des
78 la proportion de députés que le
Québec peut avoir la chambre de communes
les 78 sur 338 mais il y a pas de
garantie si un moment donné le Québec
représente 15 16 17 % de la population
canadienne qui vous dit que les
provinces de provinces vont pas dire
regardez vous pouvez pas avoir 25% des
députés à l'Assemblée nationale à la
Chambre des communes si vous représentez
15 16 17 % de la population canadienne
donc c'est garde de fou auquel il fait
allusion oui on a peut-être mais est-ce
que c'est vraiment des garde-fous
importants pour préserver l'influence du
Québec à l'intérieur du Canada je
trouvais que c'était un peu mou
aujourd'hui pour Monsieur Lego parce que
pour conserver
du Québec finalement au sein du Canada
il faudra accueillir jusqu'à 100 000 ou
même plus de 100 000 immigrants selon
ses nouveaux chiffres José je sais que
vous vouliez rajouter quelque chose
oui c'est ça et ça c'est juste pour
ajouter à ce que Sébastien vient dire
c'est et ça c'est si on n'augmente pas
le nombre de sièges des autres provinces
parce que elle leur population vont
augmenter donc ce qui va faire que même
si le Québec conserve le même nombre de
sièges sa proportion va diminuer quand
même et ça c'est la continuation de la
perte de l'influence et du poids
politique à l'intérieur du Canada donc
plus la plus la proportion de la
population québécoise va diminuer au
Canada plus ça va devenir facile pour
des partis politiques de prendre le
pouvoir au fédéral de former des
gouvernements avec très peu de sièges au
Québec aussi donc ça va avoir un effet
boule de neige là au cours des
prochaines années et des prochaines
décennies alors les garde-fous n'en
parle monsieur Lego c'est passé en
raison c'est c'est très très limité là
et ça garantit pas grand chose là on
verra donc si ça va continuer si chacun
va rester campé comme ça je vais vous
parler aussi de la crise qui perdure au
Parti libéral du Québec ce soir parce
que bon au parti libérale et certains
disent que les jours sont comptés pour
dominer qu'england en tant que chef du
parti aujourd'hui on a vu deux nouveaux
députés qui ont voulu démontrer leur
soutien envers Dominique England on va
les écouter
avez-vous toujours confiance dans les
deux chiffres de Dominique Anglet
nous on est ici justement comme des
comme des nouveaux libéraux ça fait à
peine un mois qu'on est ici
on supporte notre chef on est ici en
démonstration de notre histoire pour
notre chef oui on a toujours confiance
en Lui deux chiffres de la
Valérie vous voyez ça comment cette
sortie publique de deux nouveaux députés
encore assez inconnus du public qui
viennent démontrer leur appui comme ça
est-ce que c'est parce qu'on les connaît
pas tant que ça mais je n'ai pas senti
non plus d'appui d'une chaleur et d'une
vigueur exceptionnelle
oui dans l'extrait que vous avez passé
des termes comme c'est un peu derrière
nous on est content que ce soit du passé
alors c'était presque de s'excuser tout
en appuyant alors on peut pas dire que
c'était une démonstration de force et
ici on met dans le dans la balance
toutes ces gens qui depuis plusieurs
jours sortent dans les médias critiques
anonymement ou non évidemment peut-être
que ces deux appuis là bien que fort
fort sympathique et empathique pour la
chef ne font pas
Sébastien j'entendais ce midi
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des coups de fil
qui se passeraient pour trouver un
successeur à Dominique Anglade oui et ça
ça doit être prévu bonjour madame
Anglade c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
sait qu'il est fragilisé la question
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'elle est
capable d'asseoir son autorité au parti
libérale et bien des sceptiques dans la
salle et le fait que des gens commencent
à passer des coups de fil pour sonder le
terrain c'est pas nécessairement
directement auprès de gens qui
pourraient la remplacer mais pour se
consulter voir si ce serait pas temps
justement de changer la garde au parti
libérales c'est un très mauvais signe
pour Madame anglaise ça l'isole encore
plus il y a pas beaucoup de monde qui
sort sur la place publique pour la
défendre en ce moment il y a plus de
monde qui sort sur la place publique
pour la critiquer alors le fait que ça
grenouille comme ça c'est la fragilise
encore plus ça l'isole encore plus mais
ce qu'on ce qu'on entend c'est qu'elle
veut s'accrocher certains diront qu'elle
est déterminée d'autres pourraient dire
qu'elle est entêtée mais pour l'instant
elle a pas l'intention de de quitter son
poste du moins un court terme José
serait-elle mieux de quitter par
elle-même ou attendre de se faire
montrer la porte c'est un peu la
question qui se pose
mais pour le moment en effet c'est tout
le contraire madame Anglade s'accroche
s'accroche s'accroche et s'accroche là
bon toute griffe sorti mais que
voulez-vous c'est quand même pas tous
les jours qu'on voit en si peu de temps
après une élection une chef qui a quand
même livré une défaite historique à son
parti ne pas démissionner sur le champ
ne pas laisser la place à quelqu'un
d'autre à une possibilité de
reconstruction et que là on voit en
effet sur la place publique il y a plein
de monde qui tire à vous les roses là
sur le lit de Chypre de Madame Anglade
donc oui techniquement elle peut
toujours s'entêter mais écoutez c'est
impossible qu'elle tienne le coup là
dans cet état là juste pour confiance
non mais politiquement je veux bien là
mais bon mais politiquement c'est
serviette intenable aussi déjà intenable
alors vous imaginez le 29 novembre
que l'Assemblée nationale vont être
convoquées vous avez une chef de
l'opposition officielle terriblement
affaiblie traiter tous les noms par ses
propres troupes et elle va se lever pour
poser des questions au Premier ministre
ça va être très difficile lorsqu'elle
n'a pas l'appui de son propre parti
incluant les bombes de ce parti-là en
tout cas ce qu'il arrête la
stablissement et on serait pas surpris
s'il y a des gens qui sont pas des gens
en train de de préparer leur campagne ou
les deux chiens oui c'est ça
on va de confiance ce qui serait
étonnant les supporters
qu'on entend c'est qu'il y a des gens en
partie virale qui sont en train de
vouloir lui organiser son vote de
confiance et lui organiser son mode de
confiance c'est pas dans le bon sens
c'est dans l'autre sens on lui fait
perdre son vote de confiance et
s'assurer que les militants lui montrent
la porte donc ça aussi c'est un
indicateur que ça va mal vous avez parlé
du 29 novembre ça s'en bien on revient
sur le serment au roi qui est nécessaire
pour pouvoir siéger la santé nationale
avec ce qui était mentionné hier par
François Paradis dans cette décision
qu'il faut absolument avoir prêté
serment on se demande qui pourra être
sur place sauf que là il y a un
compromis qui semble se profiler la CAQ
se dit prête à adopter rapidement un
projet de loi ce qui permettrait donc de
pouvoir siéger à l'Assemblée nationale
on écoute des réactions à ce sujet là
occupe un tiers des sièges des députés
de l'opposition au total des députés de
l'opposition donc en termes de questions
en termes de présence dans les
commissions en termes de temps de débat
notamment sur les budgets etc on vise à
obtenir donc notre propre
représentativité au sein de des
opposition qui est un tiers des
oppositions ce qu'on a appris c'est ce
que ce qui était la position des autres
parties et puis on a convenu d'en
discuter entre nous pour ce qui est de
la réforme pour la réforme et de la
rentrée parlementaire les discussions
vont se poursuivre alors je vous
remercie beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en comprendre
est-ce que les députés de Québec
solidaires sont proches d'un compromis
avec la CAQ
on a l'impression on a vu que cette
révélation cette proposition aujourd'hui
un petit peu une baisse là peut-être de
temps il y a ce que j'ai hâte de voir si
c'est que quand même à l'intérieur de
québeccel derrière des plus radicaux en
initiés à Québec dans le jardinage seul
Zanetti qui a beaucoup mené la charge on
peut dire par rapport à toute la notion
de serment roi tout ça donc est-ce qu'il
y aura peut-être des fractions à
l'intérieur même du parti par rapport à
ce domaine à cette question là et voilà
donc on sent quand même que tout le
monde va peut-être vouloir peut-être
enfin avant nous envie de dire là ça
commence à faire quand même un peu de
temps là qu'on parle de toute cette
question entourage parlementarisme alors
est-ce qu'on se reconnecte pour se
rendre au 29 novembre c'est vraiment à
la gestion de l'État finalement et
l'autre question qui se pose Sébastien
vous avez peut-être la réponse pour
pouvoir voter sur un projet de loi il
faut être à l'Assemblée nationale alors
dans quel ordre ça veut se faire tout ça
il y a deux choses qui se passent en ce
moment les extraits qu'on entendait
portent sur essentiellement le travail à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'on donne
les moyens financiers de temps de parole
à Québec solidaire parce québécois pour
bien faire leur travail de parlementaire
ça c'est une chose le serment au roi
s'en est une autre et sur le serment en
roi la proposition de la Commission
Québec c'est de d'adopter un projet de
loi alors ce qu'on comprend c'est que
Québec solidaire serait prêt à attendre
l'adoption du projet de loi c'est-à-dire
quelques semaines sinon quelques mois à
faire sincèrement roi à siéger à
l'Assemblée nationale justement comme
vous dites pour faire adopter ce projet
de loi c'est moins clair au Parti
québécois aux particuliers on n'a pas de
signaux que ils veulent aller siéger
et en prétentiemment au roi donc c'est
comme si c'est plus la ligne dure au
Parti québécois et en effet si un projet
de loi qui est déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale il se pourrait que les députés
du Parti Québécois ne siègent pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas prêté serment au roi et
ne contribue pas à l'adoption du projet
de loi qui rendrait
initiative le serment roi mais donc il
pourrait arriver tout de suite après
l'adoption du projet de loi alors on
pourrait voir José que le persil
québécois aurait gagné son pari
finalement de cette façon là
je serai quand même un peu absurde qui
soit pas là depuis le début dont on
discute de cette de cette situation là
pas saint-pierre-flammon d'or
a remporté son pari il a réussi à
vraiment amener ce sujet là sur la place
publique consensus au Québec etc etc
pour gagner non non mais c'est gagné
dans les faits alors du moment où la
coalition ou le gouvernement de la CAQ
propose de déposer un projet de loi et
que les parties sont capables de
s'entendre là-dessus mais il y aura rien
de de gêna il y aura rien de gênant à ce
que les trois députés du Parti québécois
prête leur serment ils peuvent le faire
de manière créative et grâce à Paul
saint-pierre-flamondon et la
collaboration de tout le monde à
l'Assemblée nationale le problème serait
réglé pour la prochaine élection alors
je pense que là tout le monde en
sortirait gagné donc on serait à
quelques semaines finalement que ce soit
terminé la prestation de serment
Sébastien
il faudrait que les trois députés du
Parti québécois acceptent de prêter le
serment et ce sera le dernier ce sera la
dernière fois grâce à grande partie à
eux alors est-ce que je peux faire un
jeu de mots un peu facile une autre
bonprix
[Rires]
est-ce qu'on est allé jusqu'au bout de
la démarche puisqu'on doit posséder un
moment donné pour améliorer les choses
et avoir gagné notre point c'est
peut-être la question qui doivent se
poser aux particuliers on suivra ça
j'osais le goal Sébastien Movin Valérie
Gaudreault merci beaucoup bonne journée
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI